franc Perin bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on est ravi de
vous recevoir ici à la Royal Factory qui
est un lieu de spectacle vivant de
théâtre donc qui devrait évoquer
beaucoup de choses pour vous homme de
théâtre s'il en est absolument bon moi
j'ai envie de commencer par le début à
savoir connaître votre lien avec
Versailles et qu'on déroule un petit peu
le fil de votre vie extrêmement riche et
remplie et qu'on démarre bah par la
naissance parce que je crois que vous
êtes né ici ah bien sûr je suis né à
Versailles bouevard de la reine il y
avait une clinique qui était 151
bouvevard de la reine
d'accord les chirurgiens qui tenaient
cette clinique étaient des amis intimes
de de de ma mère et donc c'est pour ça
que je suis venu naître à versaill et
j'en suis ravi et vous n'habitiez pas à
versaill alors non on habitait à Paris
mais mais ma mère ne voulait que ACC av
confiance voilà avec pour ses amis vacan
cette chirurgienne et ce chirurgien qui
m'ont donc mis au monde en
1947 avec une césarienne donc c'était FO
pour ma mère et je je faisais euh je
faisais 4 kg 5 hein donc c'était bébé
voilà voyez c'était et en 47 je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez mais dites-moi ça
va me revenir peutêtre jamais il y a eu
un été il paraî hein très très chaud là
ma mère a dû en baver donc voilà bon ça
c'est bien terminé vous êtes làou
apparemment bah oui impeccable donc
après ben on retrouve versaill pas très
longtemps après puisque vous avez passé
votre bac je crois c'est ça ici auss
c'est ça parce que je suivais des cours
aau à l'école universelle qui était à
bailli et on passait le bac ici euh au
lycée Hoche donc j'ai passé mon bac au
lycée hoch et que je l'ai eu d'ailleurs
dans un bac philo un bac philo et alors
après j'ai j'ai tout de suite commencé à
travailler parce que céit attendez
attendez moi je ne suis pas encore après
je suis au moment du bac philo vous avez
fait votre
dissertation sur qui sur Molière sur
Molière déjà j'ai 17/ 20 enfin
coefficient 4 donc céit je croant et
qu'est qui s passé elle a été elle a été
publiée dans Le Figaro littéraire donc
grand honneur oui c'était formidable
tout le monde devait vous l'avez
toujours cette bien sûr bien sûr c'est
sympa de l'avir un jourou donc c'était
sur Molière c'était sur Molière ça s'est
trouvé donc c'est une personne que je
connaissais bien déjà DEP longtempsà oui
oui il m'a toujours plu Molière ça a
commencé quand alors cet amour à l'école
mais pas seulement l'auteur moi c'était
ce qui m'a intéressé c'était que tout
d'un coup je voyais que c'était un un
écrivain qui avait donc écrit des pièces
qui étaient très très drôles et en plus
qui jouit la comédie et et et qui était
comédien et tout et qu'on appelait le
patron ouais donc j'entendais appeler le
patron par parce que je lisais beaucoup
moi je voulais faire du théâtre depuis
l'âge de 4 ans ahaccord et donc voilà
et donc moè pour moi était un était un
intime de d'accord et un homme que
j'aimais beaucoup de de par sa sa
diversité de de talent non seulement écr
un homme extrêmment complet en fait
diriger une une troupe pendant 15 ans
faire vivre 45 personnes pendant 15 ans
c'était que c'est un peu votre modèle
alors c'est non mais je crois que c'est
le modèle de tous les comédiens parce
qu'on appoufin vous concrètement vous
avez quand même aussi diriger une troupe
toute proportion gardé oui oui oui
effectivement je crois que c'est mais
c'est une personne que j'aimerais bien
rencontrer là-haut en premier d'accord
et lui serrer la main parce que je
trouve que c'était ouis c'est quelqu'un
que j'aime bien voilà d'accord donc
succès avec la composition et alors
après vous avez tout de suite entrepris
des études de théâtre absolument je suis
rentré j'ai commencé à travailler dans
le théâtre j'étais régisseur c'estàd au
début derrière le plateau je me suis
fait engager en à Paris dans un grand
théâtre le théâtre Antoine j'ai eu la
chance d'être engagé comme régisseur et
quand on est régisseur on fait quoi à
peu près on frappe les trois coups on
s'occupe de tous les accessoires on
s'occupe de tout ce qu'il y a derrière
le on est l'homme de l'ombre l'homme de
l'ombre ce sont des gens très important
et c'est pour ça que je pense que c'est
important aussi quand on devient
directeur ou qu'on devient MRE en scène
ça de que de connaître à tous ces
voilà parce que ça c'est important de de
commencer par là puis j'ai eu la chance
de voir jouer moi quand enfin quand
j'avais 20
ans donc Jean Rochefort Jean-Pierre
Mariel Michel Bouquet Bernard Fresson
Delphine serrig t les soir on apprend
beaucoup plus qu'en en 10ant de cours et
et puis je prenais des cours de pars
thâtre et puis en prenant ces cours de
théâtre j'ai passé une audition et une
une dame qui s'appelait madame Marcel
tassencour a assisté à cette audition I
a su que j'étais un bon régisseur et m'a
proposé une place au théâtre montancier
à Versailles en
donc 67 68 oui c'est ça jusqu'en 69
jusqu'à tempant que je rentre au
conservatoire j'ai été régisseur et
comédien c'est-à-dire que je commençais
à jouer les deux casquettes je voilà
parce que je jouais des petits rôles je
crois que j'ai introduit tout le théâtre
français le duc la marquise l'Empereur
le roi tout je introdu tout le théâtre
français parce que parce que je jouais
les petits rôles de alors c'était
formidable pour moi et je m'occupais de
la régie bien sûr et j'ai j'avais cette
exception extraordinaire de pouvoir
dormir dans le théâtre et m'avait donné
la permission d'accord je dormais sur
une panière ou dans ou dans une cétait
votre maison c'était ma maison parce que
je rentrais pas à Paris parce que
j'avais pas j'avais pas de voiture
j'avais rien et puis de toute façon
c'était pour moi j'étais dans le théâtre
et quelques années plus
tard je suis revenu jouer dans ce
théâtre d'accord et mais c'était
formidable c'était pour moi une grande
expérience puis puis j'ai appris mon
métier vraiment vraiment et après je me
suis dit il faut que je rentre au
conservatoire je présenter au
Conservatoire donc au Conservatoire de
Paris au Conservatoire de Paris et là
j'ai eu la chance de rentrer au
Conservatoire d'avoir un maître
exceptionnel Louis saignier et et puis
puis c'est parti quoi et je suis revenu
jouer à Versailles plusieurs années plus
tard en tant en tant que vedette à ce
momentlà parce que j'étais j'étais
c'étaelle pièce une aspirine pour deux
de Woody Allen que j'avais adapté mis en
scène et joué que j'ai joué
850 fois ah là là c'est énorme je suis
venu jouer en tournée et tout et puis
quelques années plus tard Marcel
tassincour m'appelle ouais et me dit je
sais que vous avez joué les frry de
Scapin il y a il y a 10 ans c'était ça
avait été un gros succès je je veux le
mettre en scène pour le Grand Trianon en
plein air au mois de juin est-ce que
vous viendrez le jouer j'ai dit tiens C
forable on me rappelle avec ça et puis
puis jouer au Grand Trianon les
fourberis 10 ans après l'avoir jouer
ouais c'est une et et ça c'est fait là
ça a été un triomphe si bien qu'on a
rejoué l'année d'après les Fourberies de
Scapin et le mariage de Figaro c'était
en 89 pour le bicentenairef de la
Révolution hm hm que là il y a eu un
encore un Triomph extraordinaire au au
Trianon et et on jouit en plein air il y
avait 1500 personnes enfin c'est ça
faisait déjà partie de ce qu'on appelle
le mois Moler ou c'était avant touten à
voir céit bien avant pardon bien bien
avant jouit non non on jouait dans le
dans la cour de Marbre du Grand Trianon
quoi oui comme à l'époque de Louis XIV
voilà là où il y avait ouais pour
Marie-Antoinette et cetera est-ce que
vous avez vu avant que j'oublie des
fantômes dans le théâtre mont-entier
quand vous DZ àé moi j'ai toujours euh
des fantômes non je crois que tous les
comédiens qui sont venus jouer laissent
un supplément d'âme et je pense que un
théâtre est habité h par tous les
comédiens qui ont joué là donc c'est pas
hanté c'est il y a très bonnes ondes
alors ça moi je moi je les ressentais et
je je me souviens d'être venu seul en
scène enfin quand j'avais donc 20 ans à
ce moment-là sur la scène du théâtre
ptentier il y avait juste la servante
allumé c'est juste l'ampoule qu'on
laisse la nuit pour qu'il y ait un
éclairage sur sur scène et il y avait la
salle vide et tout et je et je me
souviens d'avoir dit je ferais du
théâtre je et et quand je suis revenu
des années plus tard en tant que
directeur j'ai refait la la même chose
et c'était très très émouvant c'est
incroyable quand même comme parcoursou
oui c'est c'est un destin parce c'est
vraiment versaill Molière et ça et ça
revient voilà et donc vous avez été
directeur après du montci voilà parce
qu'près Trianon le maire de versaill qui
était André Damien à ce momentl est venu
me voir en disant Marcel tassincour va
prendre sa retraite et tout est-ce que
vous ne prendrez pas la succession et là
je me suis dit écoutez laissez-moi en
faire 48 he de réflexion parce que
changer toute ma viee ma vie et ma
carrière he ou oui par que vous aviez
d'utres choses en route j'imagine je me
suis dit bah c'est un destin c'est
encore versaill qui m'appelle dans ce
théâtre où j'ai débuté bon il faut le
faire je vous avez accepté et vous êtes
resté directeur 8 ans ans 8 ans presque
10 ans ou travaux ça a fait 10 ans 10
années extraordinaires ou ça d'accord et
vous avez des je sais pas des souvenirs
Mo je n'ai que ça j'imagine mais les
meilleurs par exle que des bons j'ai que
des bons souvenirs parce que c'était
tellement extraordinaire ça a été un
cadeau et en même temps un travail
énorme c'est que ça bouleverse la vie he
d'ailleurs ça m'a eu deux
divorces gr gr au th bien sûr oui oui B
non vous savez il faut donc je dormais
au théâtre je donnais tout oui oui oui
oui j'avais ma loge mais là j'avais ma
loge
ce non non j'avais ma loge avais un très
bon canapé qui était très très très
agréable et donc oui je vivais au
théâtre 24h sur 24 pour la vie famille
c'est pas évident céta pas
mais j'étais pas seulement
directeurf comment dire artistique
j'étais un vrai Directeur Administratif
et tout donc j'ai dû apprendre ou la
dire la G mais c'était très intéressant
quand même et je continuis à jouer je
continuais à mettre en scène ouais c'est
fou quoi il fallait deux journées pour
en une quoi voilà on était deux parce
que je on a toujours été deux voilà ben
heureusement finalement j'ai le nom du
buit c'est bien tombé et et par rapport
je reviens encore à mon histoire de
momolière parce que là on est au mois de
juin et que mais c'est venu
après ben c'est moi qui c'est moi qui
suis allé dans la rue en premier avec un
Charr fais ah ben on faisait on
représentait des extraits de pièces de
Molière encore bien sûr avec les habis
de Molière avec la charrette avec le
donc avec les trateaux et et et et on
allait devant l'église de Notre-Dame sur
sur la place du marché on a été même
même à Montreuil on a été à satori enfin
on a fait t V r Oui t les qu et le
public suivait les enfants étaient là
autour C c'était extraordinaire c'était
il y avait c'était formidable c'était
c'était une idée que j'avais eu avec
François deasierre pour démarrer le Mois
Molière pour faire ça justement avec les
commerçants et tout c'était la fête
c'était extraordinaire par n'importe
quel temps par n'importe et là on est
donc on faisait ça ah bah ça perdure
maintenant ça a pris un grand essort
mais moi j'ai j'ai été je je je dois le
dire le le pionnier puisque je suis
aller dans la rue à la rencontre des
gens mais comme faisait Molière avec
théâtre h HM et les les gens il y a eu
un accueil fabulable c'était formidable
c'était extraordinaire c'était
extraordinaire on donnait des des farces
de Molière Le Médecin volant leanarel
les les fâcheux enfin des c'était ah
ouais c'était formable avec toute ma
troupe de comédien enfin que j'avais qui
était ravi de faire ça et h et après
vous avez donc vous avez arrêté d'être
votre mission de directeur directeur je
et après vous êtes parti en tant que
voilà voilà je me suis occupé de moi
après upé de vous après M occupé
beaucoup des autres parce que c'était
lourd la direction d' d' j'étais
directeur artistique du festival d'jou
pendant 3 ans après d'accord et puis
après j'ai dit allez je je voilà je
m'occuper de moi parce que et je passe
peut-être à l'écriture voilà et ben
alors on va en parler très bientôt je
vous remercie et puis on se retrouve
très vite pour parler de vos livres avec
plaisir merci au revoir au
revoir
I